breaking news the main news for the
entire country as well as the
conservative party is that Rishi sunak
has been selected unopposed there's no
runoff here as the next leader of the
conservative party and that means he's
the country's next prime minister now
what's he up to at the moment he's
upstairs in that room above us he's
addressing uh MPS we haven't seen him
yet the new prime minister the next
prime minister we haven't seen him but I
think we are going to get a statement
from him on camera at some point later
today what does a new conservative party
leader typically do well typically what
they will do is that they win the ballot
with Liz truss and Richard sunlight you
remember it was a big staged event with
with hundreds of people party members
and MPS in the room as Liz truss was
announced that she was the winner of the
members poll that was but September the
5th
um for Rishi sunak it's been announced
in a different way just amongst the
Parliamentary party I imagine what we'll
see later today is he will go to
conservative Campaign Headquarters this
is what every new conservative leader
does and then I think what we will see
tomorrow perhaps is the Handover of
power that's when Liz trust formally
exits number 10 has an audience with the
King and then the new prime minister has
an audience with the King and makes that
Journey from Buckingham Palace to the
podium outside in the street and he will
address the nation I think we will see
him a bit later on camera today but what
a moment this is Rishi sunak he was down
and out July he was out of cabinet he
was back on the back benches there were
questions about whether or not he would
even remain as a prime minister he now
becomes the youngest prime minister
since Sydney polionic Wars at the end of
the 18th century Pitt the younger was
the only one that was younger than him I
think he's just 4 32 years old even
younger than me sadly for me huh he is
the fast British Asian prime minister
he's the fast practice in Hindu as prime
minister this really is a groundbreaking
moment for the country in so many ways
but it's also controversial because he
has been made prime minister III uh
conservative prime minister since the
2019 general election we have Boris
Johnson then Liz truss then Rishi sunak
opposition parties are saying this is
not acceptable he doesn't have a mandate
to take over and they are calling for a
general election I think Rishi sunak's
message will be to try and beat that off
his message will be that he will lead
according to the 2019 Manifesto one of
Liz truss's big mistakes was to try and
divert from a Manifesto with her
parliamentary party saying hang on a
minute Liz trust you don't have the
Mandate so we haven't had what which is
so not saying to MPS now I imagine he
will be talking about what he intends to
do on the economy what's he going to do
on the Northern Ireland protocol bill
you saw earlier that the European
research group that's a big part of what
they care about what's he going to do on
immigration policy what's he going to do
on tax and spend and how is he going to
unite the party the first thing I think
for MPS will be politically whether or
not he creates that broad Church within
his cabinet what did he say though when
he was standing to be leader when he
made that announcement over the weekend
only when he was well past the 100 MPS
supporting him Mark he said he wanted to
unite the party and deliver for his
country he said he'd served as
Chancellor helping to steer the economy
through the toughest of times he said as
well the challenges we face now are even
greater but the opportunities to make
the right choice if we do often on a
phenomenal he said there will be
Integrity professionalism and
accountability at every level of the
government I lead and I will work day in
day out to get the job done the big
unknown of course is will the
Parliamentary party in the end let him
after all the bloodletting can they come
back together they've been positive
soundings in my initial conversations
with MPS but don't underestimate what a
vicious period this has been in the
history of the conservative party and
what a battle this prime minister has
ahead not just politically but look
what's happening to the economy problems
exacerbated problems of rise in
inflation and interest rates exacerbated
by that disastrous Liz truss mini budget
and now he has the immediate task of
trying to steady the ship and give those
big fiscal plans give those big
forecasts and also announce what he's
going to do on tax and spend in a week's
time